you know that day January 8th 2011 began
like all others you were both doing the
work that you loved you were meeting
with constituents which is something
that you love doing as a congresswoman
and mark you are happily preparing for
your next space shuttle and suddenly
everything that you had planned or
expected in your lives was irrevocably
changed forever
thanks amazing it's amazing how
everything could change for any of us in
an instant you know people don't realize
that I certainly didn't and on that
Saturday morning you know I got this
horrible phone call Gabby's chief of
staff she didn't have much other
information she just said Gabby was shot
a few minutes later I called her back
and I actually thought for a second well
maybe I just imagined getting this phone
call I called her back and that's when
she told me that Gabby been shot in the
head and you know from that point on I
knew that our lives are gonna be a lot
different and when you arrived to the
hospital what was the prognosis that
they gave you about Gabby's condition
and what recovery if anything you could
expect well for a gunshot wound to the
head and a traumatic brain injury they
they typically can't tell you much every
injury is different it's not predictable
like often a stroke might be predictable
which is another TBI kind of injury so
they didn't know how long Gabby would be
in a coma didn't know you know when that
would change and and what the prognosis
would be gabby has your recovery been an
effort to create a new Gabby Giffords or
reclaim the own Gabby Giffords
the new one better stronger tougher
I have to say you know when you look at
the picture behind us to come back from
that kind of injury and come back strong
and stronger than ever is a really tough
thing to do
I don't know anybody that's as tough as
my wonderful wife right here
what were the first signs that recovery
was not only going to be possible but
you were going to have some semblance of
the life that you and Gabby had planned
well the first thing for me was you know
Gabby was still kind of almost
unconscious but she did something when
she was in the ICU hospital bed that she
used to do when we were might be out to
dinner at a restaurant and that she
pulled her pulled my ring off and she
flipped it from one faint finger to the
next and at that point I knew that she
was still in there and there were
certain words - didn't she surprise you
with words and stuff in the beginning
what what chicken-chicken-chicken
yeah that was it for the first like
month that was the extent of Gabby's
vocabulary for some reason she she has
aphasia which is this difficulty with
communication she latched on to the word
chicken which isn't the best but
certainly is not the worst and we were
actually worried it could have been
could have been a lot worse than that
Gabby what's been the toughest challenge
for you during this recovery um talking
really hard released
yeah with with aphasia Gabby knows what
she wants to say I just can't get it get
it out yeah understands everything but
the communication is just very difficult
because you know you look at the picture
the the part of your brain where those
communication centers are or on the left
side of your head which is where the
bullet passed through so you have to do
a very dangerous thing speak for your
wife
I do
there might be some of the most
dangerous things I've ever done yeah
they are you optimistic about your
continuing recovery walking talking
being able to move your arm and leg I'm
optimistic it will be a long hard haul
but I'm optimistic that seems to be the
number one characteristic of Gabby's
always been really optimistic she works
incredibly hard every day
oh the treadmill walked on my treadmill
Spanish Alexa's French horn it's only my
wife who could be and if you knew her
before she was injured you could kind
understand this somebody who could be
injured and have such a hard time
communicating and meets with a speech
therapist and then about a month ago she
says I want to learn Spanish again well
you know let's take a little closer look
at the wife and this was even before you
met Gabby Giffords and she's on a motor
scooter there but it's my understanding
that's a very tame image of what Gabby
Giffords was like growing up yeah Gabby
knows she used to race motorcycles so
that's a scooter but she had a BMW still
has a BMW motorcycle which is she write
it well there's a challenge with not
being able to move her right arm but I
think what's um something I know about
velcro we might be able to get her back
on the bike velcro her right hand up
onto the handlebar but I'm feeling we
might see that picture next but you meet
you're already decided you that you're
going to dedicate your life to service
you going into the military and
eventually to become an astronaut so you
meet what attracts you together well
when we met oddly enough it was the last
time we were in Vancouver about ten
years ago we met a van in Vancouver at
the airport on a on a trip that we were
both taking to China that I would
actually from my background I would call
it a boondoggle
gabi with backspin emission she would
call it an important fact finding
mission she was a state senator at the
time and we met here at the airport
before a trip to China
well would you describe it as a
whirlwind romance I love a new friend
yeah we were friends for a long time and
managed and then she invited me on a
about a year or so later she invited me
on a date where do we go Gaby death row
yes our first date was to death row at
the Florida State Prison in Arizona
which was in Gabby's or just outside
Gaby's state Senate District she was
there were working on some legislation
that had to do with crime and punishment
and capital punishment in the state of
Arizona so she couldn't get anybody else
to go with her and I'm like of course I
want to go to death row so we that was
our first date
yes together ever say yes what that
might have contributed to the reason
that Gabby decided to marry you I you
know you were willing to go to death row
after all I guess
Gabby what did what did make you want to
marry my good friends best friend Jim
yeah we were friends we you know from
you know I thought we always had a very
special relationship and we've gone
through some tough times and it's only
made it stronger it's stronger after you
got married however you continued very
independent lives actually you didn't
even live together we have one of those
commuter marriages in our case it was
Washington DC used in Tucson sometimes
we'd go clockwise sometimes
counterclockwise to all those different
places and we didn't really live
together until that Saturday morning
within an hour of Gabby being shot I was
on an airplane to Tucson and that was
the moment where
that had changed for us and also GABA
you had run for Congress after being a
state senator and served in Congress for
six years what did you like best about
being in Congress fast pace mass pace
well it was the way you did yes yes
that's why I'm not sure people would
describe it entirely that way yeah you
know legislation is often at the
colossal a slow pace but but my wife and
I have to admit a lot of other members
of Congress that I know work incredibly
hard yes I mean Gabby would run around
like a crazy person
you know never take a day off maybe a
half a day off a month and whenever she
was awake she was working and she really
really thrived on that and still does
today yes installing solar panels on the
top of her house I have to say so after
the tragic incident mark he decided to
resign your position as an astronaut and
even though you were supposed to take
the next space mission everybody
including Gabby talked to you into going
back and you did end up taking kind of
AI the day after Gabby was injured I
called my boss that chief astronaut dr.
Peggy Whitson I said Peggy I know I'm
watching in space in three months from
now Gabby's in Tacoma I'm in Tucson you
got to find a replacement for me so I
didn't actually resign from being an
astronaut but I gave up my job and they
found a replacement months later coupled
me maybe about two months later started
about getting my job back which is
something you know when you when you
become this primary caregiver person
which some people in the audience here
have certainly been in that position
it's a challenging role but at some
point you got to figure out when you're
gonna get your life back and at the time
I couldn't ask Gabby if she wanted me to
go fly in the space shuttle again but I
knew she was yes yes yes she was the
biggest supporter of my career and I
knew it was the right thing to do and
yet I'm trying to imagine what that was
like going off unto a mission one
presumes safely but it's never a
guarantee and and knowing that gabby is
well not only she still she was not only
still in the hospital
on the third day of that flight
literally while I was rendezvous being
with the space station and you got two
vehicles moving at 17,500 miles an hour
I'm actually flying it looking out the
window a bunch of computers Gabby was in
brain surgery literally at that time
having the final surgery to replace the
piece of skull that they took out and
the day she was injured with a
prosthetic yeah which is the whole side
of her head now if any of you guys would
ever come to our house in Tucson for the
first time
Gabby you usually go up to the freezer
and pull out the piece of Tupperware
that has the real skull the real skull
which freaks people out sometimes is
that appetizer a dessert it gets the
conversation going but there was a lot
of conversation about something you did
Gabby after Marc's flight you had to
make another step of of courage too
because here was Congress deadlocked
again and you got out of the
Rehabilitation Center got yourself to
Washington so that you could walk on the
floor of the house I can barely talk
about this vacu emotional and cast a
vote which could have been the deciding
vote the debt ceiling the debt ceiling
yeah we've had we had that vote about I
guess about five months after Gabby was
injured and she made this bold decision
to go back a very controversial vote but
she wanted to be there to have her voice
heard one more time yes and after that
resigned and began what has been a very
slow and challenging recovery what's
what's life like day-to-day well that's
Gabby's service dog Nelson Nelson new
member of our faith
yes yes and we got him from prison
earlier we have a lot of connections
with prisons apparently Nelson came from
a prison raised by a murderer in
Massachusetts but he you know he's the
she she did a great job with this dog
he's a fabulous services so Gabi what
have you learned from your experiences
the past few years what have you learned
from deeper deeper floral relationship
your relationship is deeper it has to be
you're together all the time now you're
right
imagine being being grateful to write
grateful this is the picture of family
and friends gathering but I love these
pictures because they show the Gabby and
Mark relationship now yes and you
describe it Gabby over and over when as
deeper yes on so many levels
yes I think when something tragic
happens in a family it could pull people
together does s watch in the space
shuttle fly over over Tucson Space
Shuttle Endeavor the one that I was the
commander on its last flight on its
final flight on top of an airplane on a
747 on its way to LA NASA was kind
enough to have it fly over at Tucson and
of course the two of you go through
these challenges of a slow and difficult
recovery and yet Gabby how do you
maintain your optimism and positive
outlook I want to make the world a
better place
and you're doing that even though your
recovery has to remain front and center
for both of you you are people who are
war service to your country and you are
continuing to do that with a new
initiative a new purpose and at Gabby
what what's on the agenda now American
for Responsible solutions that's our
that's our political action committee
where we are trying to get members of
Congress to take a more serious look at
gun violence in this country and to try
to you know pass some reasonable
legislation
you know this affected us very
personally but it wasn't what happened
to Gabby that got us involved it was
really the 20 murdered first graders and
kindergartners in Newtown Connecticut
and the response that we saw afterwards
where well I mean look what's happened
so far so far the National response has
been pretty much to do nothing where
we're trying to change that yes they've
been 11 mass shooting since Newtown a
school a week the first two months of
last year what are you doing that's
different than other efforts to balance
rights for gun ownership and
responsibility for gun owners we support
gun rights at the same time we've got to
do everything we can to keep guns out of
the hands of criminals and the
dangerously mentally ill it's not too
difficult to do that this issue like
many others have become it's become very
polarizing and political and we're
trying to bring something about some
balance to the debate in Washington
thank you both for that effort and not
surprisingly for this woman of courage
and a sense of adventure
you just keep challenging yourself and
the sky seems to be the limit I'll have
to share this video of your most recent
adventure take a look at Gabby
a couple months ago
[Music]
just say one of the guys that Gabby
jumped with that day was a Navy SEAL who
she met in Afghanistan who was injured
in combat had a really rough time Gabby
visited him when he was at Bethesda and
went through a really tough period he
started doing better
months later Gabby was shot in the head
and then he supported her while she was
in the hospital in Houston so they have
a very very nice connection a wonderful
moment because this is the Ted stage
Gabby I know you worked very hard to
think of the ideas that you wanted to
leave with this audience thank you hello
everyone thank you for inviting us here
today it's been a long hard haul but I'm
getting better
I'm working hard lots of therapy speech
therapy physical therapy and yoga too
but my spirits strong as ever I'm still
fighting to make the world a better
place and you can too get involved with
your community
be a leader set an example be passion be
courageous be your best thank you very
much
thank you everybody thank you